we had a good exchange today with the
IMF on their findings of the
intermission relating to the article for
consultations with the euro area for the
first time since a crisis all your area
member states are forecasted to grow of
course there are risks risks from the
inside relating to political instability
or possible instability and risk from
the outside relating to new government
in the US and the brexit second let me
talk about Greece the good news is that
the Greek economy is recovering faster
than anyone expected and there are also
strong dynamics on the fiscal side with
better than expected revenues and we've
also heard that Greece is set to over
perform its 2016 fiscal targets the
institutions and Greek authorities will
remain engaged in constructive
discussion with a view of a quick return
of the mission to Athens and reach that
staff level agreement as soon as
possible in the case of spade is the
first time I have to underscore that the
Commission concludes that the draft
budget plan is broadly in conformity
which is progress and good step forward
and now this had need to be adopted for
2017 and implemented as soon as possible
in the case of Lithuania if certain
significant pension and employment
market report our reforms are made then
it would probably fall into conformity
and we could be in line to make progress
and in spring I think we can look
forward positively on either than
Portugal we do not see repayment risks
of course the two countries are very
different in very different positions
from the market perspective but I'm
confident and the minister talked about
that if they address these issues then
also markets will react to that
positively